finally tonight this week's edition of
notable quotables I am waiting and when
he got this letter from the president he
must be having a giggle fit I think the
president didn't want to be played with
the art of diplomacy is a lot harder
than the art of the deal we will crush
them Iran will never again have carte
blanche to dominate the Middle East gas
prices could keep going higher all
summer long
[Music]
we now call it Spygate the swamp has
never been more foul or more fetid than
under this president president she is a
world-class poker player this was not a
quid pro quo or anything else we want
people to be respectful to national
anthem we want people to stand I stand
on the shoulders of heroines who never
sought public acclaim deputy attorneys
general were very low profile tend not
to be recognized thank you very much
very nice I can attest that one can be
chief justice without being a big wheel
of any kind even tattoos I am in faith
would you feel compelled to say mr.
president you got to change your phone
it's a security risk wouldn't you at
least do that for America I have to jump
a wall to be here are you coming with us
a Russian hat
[Applause]
that is always an awesome moment when
the mids tossed their hats at graduation
that just earlier today in Annapolis and
who knew that Minnesota congressman
keith Ellison could sing and play the
guitar